[Aplausos]
[Música]
Ecuador vuelve a estar en
llamas apenas dos meses y medio es es el
tiempo que le ha durado la tranquilidad
al nuevo presidente Daniel noboa un
presidente que ahora está haciendo
frente a la que puede ser una de las
mayores amenazas que el estado
ecuatoriano ha sufrido en décadas
hablamos Ni más ni menos que del intento
del crimen organizado de Tom el control
en otras palabras que ahora Ecuador está
luchando por evitar convertirse en un
estado fallido queridos amigos amigas de
visual politic no se trata de ninguna
broma fijaos ejecución de guardias
secuestro de policías soldados en las
calles la jornada de terror que deja al
menos 10 muertos en Ecuador Es un paso
más de una tendencia peor que mala una
auténtica carrera sin freno hacia el
desastre amigos en los últimos años la
cosa en Ecuador se está yendo de madre
ahora bien alguno de vosotros piensa que
estamos exagerando pues fijaos sin ir
más lejos en el crecimiento exponencial
de la tasa de homicidios fijaos
fijaos tal y como podéis ver tan solo en
el último año entre 2022 y 2023 los
fallecidos por muertes violentas en el
país han pasado de 4500 a algo más de
8000 prácticamente el doble si en 2022
ya se alcanzó el récord histórico de
muertes violentas desde que hay
registros en este país en 2023 ese
récord fue completamente pulverizado y
ahora todo apunta que 2024 puede ser
muchísimo peor hoy por hoy en Ecuador
muere violentamente una persona casi
cada hora la violencia de las bandas del
crimen organizado está siendo bestial
tanto luchando entre ellas como contra
el propio estado pero por si esto fuera
poco ahora amigos la situación parece
estar escalando aún más hasta el punto
de amenazar el propio control del Estado
ecuatoriano sobre el territorio y las
instituciones públicas precisamente por
eso nooa se ha visto obligado a declarar
en el país un estado de conflicto armado
a nivel interno ha declarado el estado
de excepción para que así el ejército
pueda tomar el control de las calles y
también de las cárceles Incluso se ha
impuesto un toque de queda a las 11 de
la noche entre otras muchas medidas En
otras palabras ha llegado la mano dura
el ejército de Ecuador detiene a 329
terroristas en 24 horas ahora bien qué
está pasando exactamente en Ecuador qué
demonios ha hecho que las cosas se
desmadran tanto puede el país terminar
convirtiéndose en todo un estado fallido
en manos de los narcos Pues bien
veámoslo
el poder de los polvos
blancos
Ecuador le ha declarado la guerra al
crimen organizado después de que el
líder de uno de los principales grupos
criminales del país escapase de la
cárcel hablamos concretamente de Adolfo
Macías alias Fito el líder de los
choneros un grupo narc criminal que está
asociado Ni más ni menos que con el
cártel de Sinaloa amigos el domingo 7 de
enero de 2024 fitos escapó de la cárcel
del litoral de Guayaquil llevaba 13 años
encerrado cumpliendo una larga condena
de 34 años su salida de la cárcel supuso
todo un terremoto social y ahí ahí No
termina todo dos días de después el 9 de
enero se fugaba también Fabricio colom
pico alias El capitán pico que es
considerado el líder de los lobos pero
para situarnos bien y no perdernos
dejadnos que primero echemos un vistazo
a groso modo a la estructura que tiene
el narcocrimen en Ecuador
fijaos fundamentalmente podemos
encontrar tres grandes grupos criminales
los choneros cuyo líder es eluido Fito
los lobos liderados por Fabricio Colón
pico alias capitán pico y los tiguerones
que es una excisión de los choneros
liderada por Alex Salazar Villamar por
un lado el crimen organizado está muy
vinculado al tráfico de drogas
especialmente de cocaína así como a los
asesinatos por encargo y al tráfico de
armas Pero eso no es todo Estos no son
los únicos grupos criminales que podemos
encontrar en el país los lagartos Los
chone Killers y los Latin Kings tienen
también mucha actividad en la práctica
todos estos grupos criminales
Ecuatorianos funcionan como filiales de
los cárteles mexicanos y en men menor
medida también de los
colombianos por ejemplo en esta línea
los tiguerones y Los Lobos están
vinculados al Cártel de Jalisco Nueva
Generación mientras que los choneros
están asociados como ya os hemos dicho
al cártel de Sinaloa Pues bien estos dos
cárteles son acérrimos enemigos en
México y la cuestión es que ahora ese
enfrentamiento se ha trasladado también
a los grupos criminales Ecuatorianos los
choneros están en guerra contra los
tigron y Los Lobos un conflicto que
además está recrudeciendo los últimos
años pero ahora bien cómo diantes una
guerra entre bandas criminales de
termina convirtiéndose en todo una
amenaza real para el control del Estado
Esta es la pregunta Pues bien la
respuesta corta es muy simple la
situación se ha escapado de control y es
que veréis estas bandas controlan las
cárceles controlan los barrios e incluso
de facto también controlan puertos a
través de los cuales exportan sus
mercancías el gobierno ecuatoriano de
Guillermo laso fue incapaz de evitar que
esa violencia se extendiera a lo largo y
ancho del país poco a poco el control de
estos grupos es cada vez más grande la
situación es especialmente grave en la
ciudad de Guayaquil Aunque el crimen
organizado también Campa sus anchas en
esmeraldas que es el territorio de los
tiguerones amigos es muy probable que
estos días estéis escuchando muchas
noticias sobre estas ciudades y noticias
no precisamente buenas y es que
Guayaquil es la ciudad con más actividad
de estas bandas y de hecho se ha
convertido en la ciudad más violenta de
Ecuador y en una de las 25 ciudades más
peligrosas de todo el mundo digamos que
estos narc grupos utilizan su Puerto
para exportar sus mercados Garcías Es
decir para exportar la droga Pues bien
El caso es que la fuga de los dos
líderes del narco los días 7 y 9 de
enero hizo que todo estallara la
situación desde entonces es tan
surrealista que grupos armados de los
tiguerones llegaron incluso a secuestrar
el pasado 9 de enero el canal tc
televisión y lo hicieron frente a las
cámaras mientras estaba emitiendo en
directo hombres armados entraron en el
plató y se hicieron con el control de la
cadena también se ha producido seguro
que lo habéis visto el secuestro de
policías y de funcionarios en las
prisiones e incluso se han producido ya
algunas ejecuciones que han sido
retransmitidas por internet
Y es que amigos al igual que ocurre en
otros países de América Latina las
prisiones de Ecuador están controladas
en gran medidas por los propios grupos
criminales digamos que los funcionarios
apenas pintan nada y no pueden hacer
nada y eso por no decir que muchos de
ellos son corruptos y colaboran
activamente con estos grupos las
cárceles son ciudades donde los presos
mandan tienen sus propios negocios en la
regional desde que se entra ofrecen
venta de pollo asado hay una carreta de
salchipapa Morocho son negocios para
alimentar la estructura que han creado
adentro con la fuga de Fito los
criminales se vieron envalentonados y en
su nuevo pulso con el estado han llegado
a cometer auténticas salvajadas como
esta filtrado un vídeo en el que los
presos amotinados comienzan a ejecutar
guardias en las prisiones de Ecuador un
desastre un desastre que en cierto modo
se veía
venir por ejemplo no podemos olvidar que
durante la campaña electoral de las
últimas elecciones presidenciales un
grupo de sicarios asesinó al candidato
opositor Fernando villavicencio
villavicencio era uno de los candidatos
que más estaba subiendo las encuestas y
su campaña tenía un claro punto
principal la promesa de librar una dura
guerra contra el crien organizado es
decir que le mataron en plena campaña
electoral por decir cosas como estas la
policía siempre sabe dónde están
entonces en mi gobierno vamos actuar al
revés quién ataca primero no va a ser la
delincuencia la nosotros vamos a atacar
el mismo día que yo me posesione voy a
ordenar obviamente tendré que sacar a
las Manzanas podridas que están al
interior de la fuerza pública ordenar
vamos a atacar sabemos las guaridas
Dónde están los capos del narco
vacunadores extorsionadores sicarios
vamos a sacarlos de las guaridas y los
vamos a someter vamos a combatir a
narcotráfico como parte de una
estrategia transnacional la droga que
sale por este país el 90 por sale por
los puertos de Guayaquil Así es que
vamos a militarizar los puertos de
Guayaquil vamos a poner escáneres en las
principales vías vamos a crear una
policía antimafia para someter a estos
grupos terroristas Así que al final lo
que se voa a venir se hizo
realidad en los últimos días las cosas
se han escapado completamente de control
en estas últimas jornadas hemos visto
coches bomba tiroteos arrestos masivos e
incluso La amenaza por parte de los
criminales de ejecutar a cualquiera que
esté en las calles después de las 11 de
la noche que es el horario del toque de
queda también ha habido casos de gente
que ha muerto por ser alcanzada por
Balas Perdidas Como por ejemplo Un
conocido cantante del país fijaos una
bala perdida privó la vida del cantante
Diego Gallardo cuando recogía a su hijo
en un colegio en Guayaquil Ecuador y es
que aunque resulte difícil de creer en
algunos lugares de Ecuador salir a la
calle se ha convertido en un deporte de
alto riesgo terrible ahora bien llegados
hasta aquí seguro que hay una pregunta
que muchos os estaréis haciendo có
demonios ha ocurrido esto Qué explica
que un país relativamente tranquilo como
era Ecuador se haya convertido en
semejante jungla pues amigos amigas
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
atentos
ingredientes para el
desastre Ecuador ha sido históricamente
un país relativamente Pacífico al menos
para los canones de América Latina
incluso la tasa de omicidios en el país
registró en 2017 un nivel de 6 por cada
100000 una tasa alta pero tampoco mucho
más alta que la de un país europeo Como
por ejemplo letonia Sin embargo a partir
de 2019 todo empezó a salirse de madre
desde entonces el crimen la violencia y
los asesinatos han crecido
exponencialmente Ecuador ha pasado de
ser un lugar razonablemente tranquilo a
convertirse en uno de los países más
peligrosos de todo el mundo esta gráfica
que ya veíamos antes es un claro ejemplo
de ello ahora bien Qué explica este
desastre qué demonios ha pasado en
Ecuador para que se pongan tan mal las
cosas Pues queridos amigos amigas
podemos encontrar cinco grandes motivos
que explican esta
catástrofe vale seguro que esto nos
pilla de nuevas América Latina y narco
desgraciadamente Parece que son dos
conceptos que van de de la mano Sin
embargo lo cierto Es que en el caso de
Ecuador esto no era así O al menos no
del todo Sin embargo a partir del año
2019 este país empezó a convertirse en
un centro logístico primordial para los
grandes cárteles del narco a partir de
ese año el tráfico de coca de armas o el
lavado de dinero comenzó a multiplicarse
Ecuador se convirtió Por decirlo de
alguna forma en un gran proveedor de
servicios para los grandes cárteles
internacionales que se liaron entonces
con los grupos locales de esta forma
Ecuador se ha especializado en el
almacenamiento y la distribución
internacional tanto por vía terrestre
como marítima y aérea de buena parte de
la coca de los cárteles colombianos y
mexicanos una producción que entra y
sale por mar por aire y también por
tierra a través de los territorios de
tulcán to bard donoso el chical
Maldonado Urbina y el Carmelo y eso eso
no es todo en Ecuador también se ha
desarrollado una importantísima
industria especializada en el lavado de
dinero negro no olvidéis que Ecuador Es
una economía dolarizada lo que le
permite a los cárteles lavar cómodamente
sus billetes del Tío Sam Por supuesto
para que todo esto sea posible los
grupos narcocriminalidad
un montón de policías funcionarios y
políticos hasta el punto de que hoy las
instituciones ecuatorianas tienen más
agujeros que un queso bruller y claro el
problema es que llega a un punto en que
ya nada se sostiene y sabéis Qué
exactamente es ahí donde
estamos amigos la pobreza el desempleo y
la desigualdad suelen tener bastante
relación con el crimen especialmente en
las grandes ciudades Pues bien Ecuador
no es una excepción como nos comentaban
en si lo hubiera sabido en un reciente
vídeo que os dejo en la descripción
Ecuador no ha tenido precisamente un
buen historial económico en los últimos
años por cierto si aún no conocéis si lo
hubiera sabido el canal de información
financiera de mut activos con el que
participamos no olvidéis echarle un
vistazo insisto el enlace por aquí abajo
amigos la economía ecuatoriana no crece
Y para colmo un terremoto en el año 2016
y luego la covid-19 le dieron al país la
puntilla lo que ha hecho que los niveles
de pobreza y de desigualdad hayan
crecido un montón en los últimos años
desde 2019 por ejemplo tanto el
desempleo como el trabajo informal o el
subempleo han crecido al tiempo que la
pobreza pasó del 21,9 por en 2019 al
25,5 por apenas 3 años más tarde y ojo
Porque estos aproximadamente cuatro
puntos de la población suponen casi
650,000 personas más sumidas en la
pobreza y desde luego millones y
millones más sufriendo la frustración de
la falta de oportunidades y esto amigos
es el caldo de cultivo perfecto para la
emergencia del
crimen lo siento por los correístas que
podéis estar viendo Este vídeo pero
Rafael Correa también ha tenido mucho
que ver con la pésima deriva del país
primero porque sus gobiernos hicieron en
muchos casos la vista gorda con los
grupos criminales y en otros casos como
ocurrió con los Latin Kings incluso los
legalizó el resultado por ejemplo es que
Bajo su gobierno apenas hubo
incautaciones de droga además en 2009
cerró la base militar de manta una base
de Estados Unidos en Ecuador que servía
sobre todo para que la DEA y los cuerpos
especiales norteamericanos vigilarán y
perseguirán a los grupos de
narcotraficantes de la zona pero Correa
cerró la base echó a los efectivos del
país y cortó la relación con la DEA Y sí
es verdad Correa consiguió unas tasas de
violencia razonablemente reducidas
durante su mandato Pero a cambio hizo
que todos estos grupos se fortaleciera
muchísimo En otras palabras que Bajo su
presidencia se comenzó a cocinar el
desastre y ahí ahí No termina todo
durante años el presidente Correa gastó
un montón en programas sociales que sí
redujeron la violencia pero que sin
embargo fueron una especie de pan para
hoy y hambre para mañana porque la
enorme deuda y la mala situación
económica que dejó Correa hizo por un
lado que los grupos criminales fueran
cada vez más fuertes y por otro que el
país tuviera que terminar aplicando
durísimos ajustes que terminaron
alimentando la pobreza y la frustración
y con ello Pues el caldo de cultivo
perfecto para que estos grupos
criminales crezcan y se desarrollen por
supuesto No es el único responsable sus
Sucesores en el sillón presidencial no
consiguieron hacer nada para cambiar
realmente la mala deriva del país
incluso dejaron las cárceles
completamente bajo el control de los
criminales y del narco Pero sabéis qué
en cierto modo el correísmo Aquí también
tuvo mucho que ver porque lo cierto Es
que la parálisis política que vive el
país ha sido clave la inoperancia del
Estado Pero vale dicho esto La pregunta
es por qué ha saltado todo por los aires
justo ahora pues amigos eso tiene que
ver exactamente con esto
Daniel Novoa llegó al poder el pasado 23
de noviembre como ha llegado a la mitad
de legislatura va a ser un presidente de
corta duración apenas estará en el cargo
un año y medio Esto hace que tenga muy
pocas prioridades y una de ellas será
precisamente ganarse al electorado
mejorando la mala situación de seguridad
que vive el país para lograrlo ha
propuesto medidas Como por ejemplo
instalar cárceles flotantes en barcazas
para internar allí a los delincuentes
más peligrosos y evitar que puedan
seguir operando desde sus celdas Pues
bien estas y otras propuestas no han
gust ad nada de nada los narcos que han
visto en un presidente nuevo y muy joven
la oportunidad Perfecta de tomar el
control digamos que han visto su momento
un momento porque quizás el punto más
importante que explica que el estallido
se haya producido precisamente ahora es
el último
atentos amigos A mediados de diciembre
la fiscalía del país lanzó una mega
operación contra la corrupción y el
narcotráfico que se tradujo en decenas
de redadas en distintos puntos de
Ecuador y también en la detención de 29
nueve personas entre ellas jueces
Fiscales y policías relacionados con el
crimen organizado para que os hagáis una
idea entre los arrestados se encontraba
Ni más ni menos que willman Terán el
presidente del Consejo de la judicatura
el órgano que controla a los jueces Pues
bien tras este operativo la fiscal
general Diana Salazar terminó publicando
serias acusaciones sobre cómo los narcos
han infiltrado el conjunto del país el
caso metástasis es una radiografía de
cómo el narcotráfico se ha tomado las
instituciones del estado para a través
del dinero mal habido operar desde
instancia judiciales y políticas y
lograr impunidad en algunos casos esto
amigos alteraba el estatus quo con el
que los narcocriminalidad
Así que esta ha sido su reacción un
enorme golpe en la mesa queridos amigos
amigas Esta es la terrible situación de
Ecuador y los motivos que nos han traído
hasta aquí ahora la pregunta es creéis
que noboa conseguirá controlar la
situación qué haríais vosotros para
enfrentaros a los narcos dejadnos
vuestras respuestas en los comentarios y
habramos debate y ahora si este vídeo os
ha resultado interesante no olvidéis
darle al botón de like y suscribiros
aviso al politic si es que aún no lo
habéis hecho Ah Y también no olvidéis
echar un vistazo aí lo hubiera sabido
una vez más Muchas gracias por estar ahí
un saludo y hasta la
[Música]
próxima